hi everybody and welcome to another
episode of our kevinsites so last week
there was a really cool event in the air
I can be openly i-5 a system of five
neural networks build by a nonprofit
organization opening I took on a team of
five professional gamers in the very
complicated game of dota 2 so the match
consisted of three games the first two
were normal draft games giving each side
equal chances of winning and after
relatively short game times opening i-5
was able to convincingly beat more
dead-on open a I open the base up for a
second set of racks and GG will be
called 21 minutes in but then the second
game was a little bit different since
the life audience on Twitch was allowed
to choose the heroes to be played by the
bots resulting in very unbalanced teams
and an estimated win probability of
opening I five of only two point nine
percent
two point nine percent chance that open
now is gonna win what they're scared is
everybody you guys an esteemed three was
a clear victory for Team human but
surely will not be enough to save open
AI here
and how many people are probably
wondering why would a world-class
research organization like open e I
spent so much time and effort trying to
build an AI that can play simple video
games the reality however is that it has
become commonplace in the AI community
to test the progress of deep
reinforcement learning algorithms on a
wide variety of games because they
provide a perfect testbed for measuring
the progress of ever more complicated
AI systems and while for unexperienced
gamers these games might seem trivial
and uninteresting they can actually pose
surprisingly difficult challenges for
current AI systems and therefore provide
the ideal training grounds for measuring
and building progress in the field and
additionally is this very commonly
machine learning land I've seen a wide
range of opinions covering opening i-5 I
mean really I've seen everything from
Elon Musk's trash-talking dota bolts
that spanked up to your humans all the
way to machine learning researchers that
are claiming that this doesn't provide
any useful knowledge for the community
since these bots are simply overfitting
to an endless amount of training data so
because of all that in this episode I
want to systematically dismantle the
open era file system
starting from a general overview of what
this means for the progress of AI
research all the way to the specific
implementation details and the computer
resources that were used to train
opening i-5 and then in part two of this
episode which will be a different video
I will dive into all the technical
details of the reinforcement learning
algorithm behind opening i-5 which is
called proximal policy optimization I
hope you're ready to dive in deep my
name is Andrew and welcome to archived
insights
[Music]
so after the successes of deep
reinforcement learning in benchmarks
like Atari and go it was time to move on
to even bigger problems and a game like
dota 2 definitely has a lot of these now
to get a sense of why these games are so
difficult for reinforcement learning i
really suggest to check out my video in
the sparse rewards in case you haven't
seen it yet so one of the major
challenges in a game like dota is that
an agent has to take thousands of
actions you know moving around by
clicking the screen casting abilities
buying items and very often the payback
or the reward for those actions only
arrives much later in the game and on
top of that the output action space in
the other two is incredibly large if you
compare it with a game like Atari for
example that only has a couple of
discrete outputs or a game like go that
is played on a discrete 19 by 19 grid in
comparison in dota 2 you have to click
the map anywhere to move around you can
cast abilities you have to farm creeps
attack towers you know there's a ton of
different things that you have to do in
that output space in order to be
successful at the game and this has been
notoriously difficult for AI systems to
learn and then finally the other two is
also what we call an imperfect
information game which means that at any
given point you don't have access to all
the information of the current game
state so for example in dota 2 you have
something that's called the fog of war
which means that if an enemy is really
far away from you or they're hiding in
the forest then you can't see them but
becoming really really good at the game
actually requires you to learn how to
model their behavior and their positions
even though you don't have any labels to
train on and so all these things
combined make for the fact that while
dota 2 is just a simple video game it
actually presents a lot of challenging
problems for the current AI systems that
we have today in fact that's exactly the
reason why it was chosen as a benchmark
to test the progress in deep
reinforcement learning and we also know
that simultaneously google deepmind is
in fact working on starcraft 2 so I hope
we're gonna get to see some results from
that pretty soon now to get a sense of
opening eyes victory against Team human
consider that all five professional
players were what they call in the
ninety nine point ninety fifth
percentile
of the dota2 rankings this means that if
you were to pick $10,000 players at
random and rank them according to their
skill then these pros would be ranked
5th out of 10,000 so in other words
these guys are really really good right
so how is machine learning even able to
play a game as complex as dota 2 well
the answer is the combination of a
reinforcement learning algorithm called
proximal policy optimization that I will
cover in the next video and a self play
strategy that is combined with a lot of
computational resources so the fact that
the system learns through self way means
that you can install the game engine on
many computers and then have the
algorithm learn by playing a ton of
matches against itself gradually getting
better and I really mean a ton of
matches to be precise opening i-5 plays
about 180 years of game experience every
single day and it does this using a
scale of version of proximal policy
optimization that's running on hold on
to your chairs 128,000 CPUs and 256 of
the biggest GPUs available and even in
deep learning land that is a lot of
compute and if you're wondering how much
all of that would cost I was actually
quite surprised to discover that with
today's massive cloud infrastructure
those things are actually quite
affordable topping out at about 2,500
dollars per hour using preemptable
virtual machines in the Google cloud
platform and yes that is a lot of money
for us individuals but not if you're a
world-class research organization that
is backed by millionaires like Elon
Musk's Sam Altman Peter Thiel and many
others and now before we dive into some
specific implementation details of
opening i-5 I want to spend a few
minutes on why this victory matters and
what it means for the future of AI so
first of all I think what we learned
from this is that while the current
reinforcement learning algorithms that
we have are vastly simpler and less
capable than our human intellect if you
give them enough training data and
compute resources they can actually
solve surprisingly complex problems in
fact as we've similarly seen from the
alphago story the engineering challenge
of scaling these deep RL pipelines to
massive scales seems to be equally
important when compared to the
algorithms that drive the system
but on the other hand I also think we
should be very careful not to overstate
these achievements in terms of AI
progress as from sparkly the creator of
Kara's very accurately puts it in this
tweet any problem can be treated as a
pattern recognition problem if your
training data covers a sufficiently
dense sampling of the problem space
well it's interesting however is what
happens when your training data is a
sparse sampling of the space because to
extrapolate you will need intelligence
and clearly training a hundred and
eighty years worth of experience every
single day seems like a rather dense
sampling of the problem space so in a
sense you could say that the opening I
five system has successfully learned to
overfit on a very dense sampling of the
dura 2 problem space but undeniably this
is also allowed it to beat a team of
professional gamers showing that while
these systems might be doing nothing
more than just overfitting they can in
fact be used to create practical systems
that can tackle complex problems but
because all these innovations live in
the open-source atmosphere that
surrounds the machine learning community
it's quite likely that these will open
up a lot of new applications in fields
like finite element methods for example
so if you think about molecular
simulations or fluid dynamics I'm pretty
sure that deep reinforcement learning
can open up a way to drastically really
fine the traditional engineering process
you know I think new antibiotics better
nanomaterials optimize traffic flows
many many more but on the other hand a
lot of real-world applications don't
have access to these accurate simulators
or massive amounts of training data and
in these cases the current sample
complexity and the lack of
generalization obviously remain a
crucial obstacle and while looking at
the progress over the past 5 years might
give us some reasons to be hopeful for
the future I think we also have to admit
that currently there are no fundamental
solutions to these very big problems
like generalization and overfitting ok
so now that we have a sense of
surroundings let's start picking apart
how open and i-5 really works so first
of all how do these bolts actually see
the gate well the implemented version of
opening i-5 uses the valve bought API
for the dota game this means that
instead of seeing the rendered game
pixels that we see on the screen
the box actually have access to the
internal features of the game engine so
this includes things like hero name
health position and in the abilities
creep scores item actives all of those
things and many people see this as a
clear advantage that the bots have over
human players and this is probably true
but the truth is that that whole goal of
this opening I did a to challenge was to
see how well these reinforcement
learning algorithms can scale to very
complex environments with long time
horizons and giving the bots access to
the true game State doesn't actually
make this job all that much easier
here's a little piece of the discussion
after the match that shows that point
about the feature feature design why not
image base the features so this is
actually very correlated so so what you
really want to explore in this project
is how well can Candy's system learn to
strategize in a game if you give it a
lot of computer a lot of experience and
the problem with learning from pixels is
that even generating those pixels
you know requires running on a graphics
card requires running a graphics engine
and it is just expensive if you want to
do it on a ton of machines it would just
force us to use a lower scale for
training so that is our primary reason
we just don't want to spend time to view
the graphics want to want to focus on
the strategy the logic thank you thanks
and additionally given enough training
data it's quite likely that a supervised
learning approach using deep
convolutional networks would probably be
able to discover the raw game state
using only raw pixels as an input the
reality is that learning to detect
specific features in a visual scene or
quickly reacting to an enemy ability is
actually not that difficult in fact it's
where machine learning shines but the
really hard task is to learn
sophisticated plans over long time
horizons in complex environments like
data - alright so the board has access
to the internal features of the game
engine now it's quite likely that there
occasionally adding new features but in
the June 25th blog post of opening AI
they mentioned that the bot sees the
world through a list of 20,000 numbers
and according to the updated network
diagram of the August 6 system they add
a 10 by 10 mini map which has a couple
of
channels for vision walkability creep
and ward locations and which gets
processed by a small convolutional
network and then finally all these
features are concatenated and passed on
to a single layer lsdm cell that parses
the inputs and emits actions through
several possible action heads and in the
initial blog post opening i mentioned
that the lsdm had a hidden state size of
1,024 values but this was scaled up to
2048 in the latest version and now let's
take a look at the reward function which
is another fundamental difference with
the alphago system for example
so while alphago had a very simple
binary feedback bit at the end of the
game for either winning or losing the
opening I 5 reward function was heavily
heavily shaped by people who know a lot
about the dota 2 game and who understand
the optimization algorithm so here for
example we can see that many sub goals
in the game like farming creeps killing
enemy heroes destroying buildings all
have their own hard-coded rewards so
obviously this makes it a lot easier for
the agent to discover successful
behavior and another major difference
with the alphago system is that opening
at 5 doesn't use any kind of Monte Carlo
enrolls so it simply picks the top
action from its policy network based on
the current lsdm state and the reason is
of course because it's impossible to do
rollouts in a game like data 2 but I
think it's interesting to recall how big
of a difference that Monte Carlo rollout
actually made in the alphago system and
apart from all this reward shaping
opening high five also uses hard coded
item builds and skill leveling orders
although openly I mentioned that they
were experimenting with having the bolts
learn this from scratch as well and then
finally I'd like to end with a few
things that I found really interesting
when watching the live matches so first
of all I think a lot of people including
myself were very surprised by how
heavily influenced the win rates were by
the hero draft and according to the
open-air blog post in late June they
added a win probability output to the
neural network to retrospect what ai-5
was predicting and when they later
considered drafting they realized that
they could use this to evaluate the win
probability of any draft simply look at
the prediction on the first frame of a
game and use that one to make a tree
that you can then
you search on and I'm guessing that this
could become a very interesting feature
for professional gamers during draft
picks and then a lot of people were also
noticing that the bots were sometimes
warding in very strange places and if
you think about it that kind of makes
sense because how would you design a
reward function for placing Ward's I
mean it's not that simple
instead the opening I team decided they
would just add in the ability to ward
and see what the bolts learn to do with
that by themselves and then I'm
wondering if some people notice this but
in some of the games you can actually
see the bolts quickly peeking inside the
Roshan pit and then going back out and
according to the opening I engineers
this is actually an artifact from the
randomizations that were used for
training the system so as it turns out
killing a very strong neutral monster
like Roshan is almost impossible by
doing random exploration because you
will never end up there with five
coherent heroes to actually kill that
monster and so in order to incentivize
the exploration in the algorithm to
actually learn that Roshan is a very
useful objective to take what they did
is that every training game Roshan had a
random amount of health so sometimes
when the bot was really lucky it could
encounter a rush on that only had a
hundred health and was you know able to
kill it all the way by itself and get
the buffs for the entire team and this
actually allowed the algorithm to learn
that taking an objective like Roshan has
a lot of useful reward but as you can
see this has also left an artifact in
the boss policies to sometimes go and
check if Roshan is not low health as
well sometimes the case in the training
games and then for me personally I think
the third game was actually the most
interesting because in the third game
the bots were starting the game with a
really really high disadvantage and they
quickly started getting behind and at
some point you could really see that the
bots were very very confused
they didn't really have a specific
strategy for dealing with that situation
of being so far behind and so I think
the reason for this is that while
training through self play you will not
often get a situation where one of the
sides is losing very very heavily
because by definition you're playing an
opponent
that is almost equal strength and these
guys have you seen if they can join
teams so I guess this clearly proves the
point by francois collect on densely
sampling your data distribution and so
all in all while it's definitely true
that this victory doesn't imply a
significant breakthrough in AI theory i
think we can all say that it was a very
impressive engineering achievement
opening i five showed impeccable
teamfight skills came up with a very
aggressive but successful meta and as
was the case with alphago will probably
have a lot of impact on the future of
dota 2 gameplay and so the hope is now
that these achievements will trigger a
whole range of new real-world
applications that are combining these
deep reinforcement learning systems with
very accurate simulators or a lot of
training data that is densely sampled
from the problem space and finally don't
forget if you want to dive into the nuts
and bolts of the algorithm behind
opening i-5 be sure to check out the
follow-up video to this episode which
will dive into proximal policy
optimization if you like this video and
you want to keep learning about AI don't
forget to subscribe my name is Xander
and I thank you very much for watching
archived insights
you